tonight it's my pleasure to welcome Neil
McLaughlin to the Hastings Hall podium
as this terms Lord Norman Foster
visiting professor in architecture the
foster chair was endowed by Norman
Foster and his family Norman Foster is a
1962 graduate of our school as many of
you know and has always been an
outstanding model for excellence in our
profession on many occasions Lord
Foster's in Galt and acknowledged his
death to Yale where he encountered great
teachers in particular Paul Rudolph
Serge Tamiya and Vincent Scully and in
Foster's own words experienced a studio
atmosphere which was highly creative and
competitive with the kind of can-do
approach that is influenced and inspired
his practice for more than 40 years and
continues to do so I quote end of quote
the foster chair is intended to attract
top teaching talent to our advanced
studios and in particular to ensure the
continuing presence that Yale of
international visiting faculty previous
foster professors have been David
Chipperfield Alejandro ziyarah polo zaha
hadid
be joy Jane and David ah Jay last fall
John Pat cow completed the third of his
terms as foster professor Jim McLaughlin
is a graduate of University College
Dublin where he completed at that
institution all three parts of the
five-year RI BA program of study which
culminates in registration and
recognition as a professional architect
in the United Kingdom they're still not
you know Ireland and England are still
at war with each other so that is a
little piece of a feat to study in one
and get registered in the other during
and directly following his academic
studies he worked in the offices of the
uk-based firm Scott tau and Walker
in 1990 professor McLaughlin entered
into independent practice setting out to
develop a portfolio of diverse building
types in 2000 he was named young British
architect of the year in 2002 his firm
was one of eight recognized by
architectural review and the RI ba was a
prestigious emerging architecture award
recently Neil McLaughlin architects has
been widely recognized for the bishop
Edward King chapel for Ripon Theological
College in cuddlin Oxfordshire which was
shortlisted in 2013 for the our ib ace
Stirling Prize Professor McLaughlin has
been a visiting professor at the
Bartlett School and I think continues to
be so in London and at the University of
California in Los Angeles please join me
in welcoming to Yale this terms Norman
Foster visiting professor Neil
McLaughlin as he delivers lecture
origins and translations
thank you very much I thought I would
begin this lecture on origins and
translations by speaking a little bit
since I'm teaching here this year about
some of my teachers and I've chosen
three drawings which I thought would be
relevant from my time at University
College Dublin the first one I can't
explain the impact that these drawings
had on me when I saw them first at the
age of 17 arriving into University
College Dublin my first day and being
invited to see the drawings for the
competition for the Irish President's
House and the second place scheme was
designed by an architect called Shane
deblocking who had been on the project
team on the Paul Mellon Center and the
Yale Center and Louie Kant are the the
the Exeter librarian in in Louie Kahn's
office and he came back from that office
with an extraordinary sense of other
architecture walls and we had him in
first year and fourth year the impact
that he had on us as first years out of
the bogs and the suburbs with no idea
what architecture was about was profound
he felt that architecture became really
architecture when it couldn't be spoken
about and much of his teaching was
conducted in deep silence he believes
strongly in the power of institutions
and in the room as the as the bedrock of
architecture and these drawings here
show the strongly county and spirit
which he brought to the school and that
discipline was innocent central to my
education and his powerful sense of the
vocation and the mystique of the figure
of the architect was it was something
which I think he brought from the week
on the second drawing and perhaps the
most important my own mentor a Robin
Walker who had studied with Mies van der
Rohe who was would lecture on this
detail and only on this detail and he
felt exercised about it to the point of
distress the idea that the corner column
in the Lakeshore Drive apartment
building it could be a steel
load-bearing column encased in fireproof
concrete
then Rhian case in steel injured his
sense of what I would think of as being
the anglo-american interpretation of
Mies van der Rohe which comes from Puget
and the Arts and Crafts movements the
idea that architecture is a
truth-telling capacity or that there's
something transparent about construction
and in a sense the way in which that
exercised him is something that I've
brought through my through my life and
the understanding which the deeper study
of Mies has given me which is that
architecture is always representation
and looking at the antecedents of Mises
work in people like semper bata sure the
people who came from German idealism and
the understanding of the representative
function of architecture is something
which will be significant in the rest of
the project
and finally this drawing by O'Donnell
and to me for the Irish cinema Building
in Dublin coming fresh from James
Sterling's office when I was a student
and reinvigorating the school with this
interpretation of the European tradition
and this strong loyalty to the existing
context this first design of there's a
complete reworking of existing buildings
in the centre of Dublin which eventually
produce a redesign of the whole of the
central quarter of Dublin and led by
them and other practices and so those
are in a sense the origins that I have
come from and what I'd like to do now is
to talk about that theme in different
ways through the work of my own office I
have to say that all of those carried a
certainty about architecture which I
can't really share for me architecture
is at its best is always ambivalent and
equivocal and the sense of it being open
to multiple interpretations and having
an unsayable quality the sense of
skepticism and doubt that I think is
central to my work is not something that
I would share with these individuals
just to help those of you who don't know
these islands very well the first
project I will show you is in Dublin a
tiny room which we've recently completed
for contemplative monks and I thought
with the emphasis on calm beginning with
the room would be a good start we were
asked to design a chapel for 15
contemplative monks in a monastery and
we looked at this painting by the master
of the life of Mary the sense that
within a conventional domestic interior
that an extraordinary sacred space has
been carved out by a combination of the
screen and the furniture
within which the sort of stiff
hierarchies of heaven can be can be can
be reenacted and the sense of a kind of
a golden beyond a space a space beyond
the inhabited sacred space it's
something that we wanted to to gather in
the room and the other thing we came
across was this beautiful text from
sunburned of clairvaux who described a
church built by Maliki in the 11th
century as made of polished boards
firmly and tightly fastened together an
Irish work as beautiful as you could
wish and what I loved about this is a
the description of the construction is
actually describing a theological idea
it's showing loyalty to the Celtic
version of Christianity when Rome was
looking to centralize Christian power
and so a profound theological idea is
what is wrapped up in a construction
idea and clearly the polish boards
firmly and tightly fastened together are
the monks themselves in as much as they
are the construction of the building and
so here we have an irregular room in the
monastery a rather unprepossessing place
within which we've built a second room
in which is possible to enact the sort
of symbolic ritual of the mass and this
model here showing 12 chair is
representing the 12 disciples gathered
around the central table and that those
chairs rise up and become the structure
of the room which contains the space for
the ritual and the chair itself has
developed in great detail with the
priests so that it's perfectly
comfortable perfectly well-lit place for
prayer books and so on but that the
columns rising out of the chair then
become a screen which is backlit to give
you that space beyond and the fine
detail of that then and the construction
looking at the tradition of the medieval
mizerock or the seats let into the
structure itself and here we have the
monks gathered around the altar what we
wanted to do is he uses a chair to sort
of dignify and increase the height of
the seated figures in such a way that
that the vertical scale of the figures
would mean that the monks sitting
opposite each other would feel close
together and that gives you a sense of
what the God that space is like a
combination of natural and artificial
light so as the evening comes in you get
this illumination
space building up the next one is
looking at the idea of place in a
different kind of way it's a sort of
traditions of materials and environment
a beautiful site in West Cork in Ireland
almost one of the most westerly points
in Europe you can see the Fastnet
lighthouse from this site the facet
lighthouse was famous and that the last
people the lighthouse keeper was the
last person to see both the Titanic and
the Lusitania so it is the most remote
place in Europe and there's a famous
yacht race goes around the fast note and
this beautiful bay here the site has got
a view out onto the fastness itself what
we did was to think about there's the
sloping rock surfaces that go down into
the sea a lovely metamorphic rock and to
think about the building has been
contained in the meadow between these
sloping rock surfaces and that it would
have a really primitive geometric
quality as though it was dumbing the
stream which you can see in this drawing
which flows down into the sea and the
plan of the building is very simple I
don't know if I have a pointer here if I
do oh this the plan of the building is
very simple an existing cottage on the
site you arrive down into the building
and you see a fire lit here and the
freestanding fireplace and which has
been lit by the housekeeper before you
arrive you come in the front door beside
the fire and as soon as you do you look
through this window and the only thing
you can see is the surface of the sea
through that window and it brings you
down through a series of volumes which
are contained between these rock faces
in this meadow going down to the sea and
each of these absorbs has made
completely of stone all the way down
you've guest bedrooms master bedroom
dining room kitchen and eventually you
come to this huge window with a view out
to the Fastnet the little study here is
built as a separate block and the stream
which comes down from the mountain fills
a pool here before passing through the
building and flowing out into the sea
and we were looking to try and use the
quality of this lovely metamorphic rock
to produce a very simple and primitive
architecture and the place I love this
building and I'll come back to it later
it's a an eighth century chapel on the
west coast of Ireland and I love its
kind of Inglot like quality its
primitivism
the sense that it's kind of irreducibly
simple that was what I thought when I
was designing this project I wanted to
characterize in it I looked at it later
on and found it far more complex than
I'd assumed but I'll talk
that little later what we wanted to do
is to design a building that would have
that quality and we call it an inca
light quality and the other motif we use
was this lovely Albers drawing painting
of interconnected forms we thought
wouldn't it be good to have a building
that shared these properties so working
on models on the building you can see
that it's the same plant here with the
stream flowing down going into a pool
going between the two buildings the
existing cottage here just tidied up the
access down to the sea and the way in
which you move through these different
volumes to get and finally the the
living room at the end and really to
make the simplest possible form which is
an in situ cast concrete structure very
high thermal mass heavily insulated and
then cloud in this blue limestone on the
outside and that everything in the
building the interior the external
paving the lime the the walls and the
roof are all made from this load-bearing
Ashtar limestone and we wanted to do is
to use that limestone in a way you can
see the containment between these
sloping rock faces on each side you can
see the reflection of the rock faces and
in this image to use the limestone in
two ways the windows in the building
when they face the sea are placed right
on the outside giving you a very deep
reveal inside and one at the end of the
gables are pushed right back in giving
you this kind of deep shading of the
glass at the ends of the kind of mega
Ron volume and so the building has just
built up by a combination of those wood
slots between them when they combined
together they make this kind of
accommodation of forms the inside as
well as made completely from the blue
limestone and by I'm particularly fond
of in this material you can see here the
depth of the reveal on the inside
looking at the depth of the reveal on
the outside and that play between
pushing the glass between the two
surfaces and well I was particularly
keen on this building is that in the
West of Ireland they say it's either
raining or it's just about to rain and I
wanted to make a building that would be
beautiful when it's raining but also in
that kind of fugitive light that you get
after a rain and the sense that the
building when it's wet would be its best
moment and you can see it here dry it
there was a kind of pale parchment color
that's the gap which the stream flows
between but when the Sun comes out after
a rain the building turns into a
complete
we wanted that to be something that
would catch that sense of the sky and
the maritime light that you get in the
West of Ireland and here the simple
thing of the stream flowing down into a
courtyard the sight is incredibly bleak
and the salt wind coming in I had a
substantial bet with the client that the
tree we planted would never survive but
we've managed to make this sheltered
court and the tree that is a strawberry
tree has managed to survive so far and
you can see here that sort of almost
monastic sense we have of the deeply cut
stone volume and using the depth of the
reveal to create these simple sculptural
shapes and to try and think back to that
Albers painting that primitive quality
that the simple Chapel had of a stone
simple stone building standing by the
sea and that shows you in a sense the
fulfillment of the promise that the
Albers drawing had given us to some
extent the issues around this building
are relatively straightforward it's a
kind of an old-fashioned idea of place
that you make the building from the
materials that you win from the ground
and the local builder builds are all
from you and to me I think that's a
possible but a very privileged way of
making buildings in this time and some
of the projects I'll speak about later
we'll look at the problems about that
kind of rough skinny an idea that notion
of the stability of place the next
project which takes you from a sort of a
resonant rural place we moved to the
centre of Oxford which is a place that
we've been significantly involved in
over the last ten years we won an
architectural competition in 2006 and
since then we've developed a substantial
body of work in the city I'm going to
speak just about that project because it
sort of refers to the notion of that
that that insistence on the form of the
European City and how you can build out
from that we had an extraordinary
opportunity on this site we were asked
to enter a competition jointly sponsored
by a college in the university which is
virtually unheard of the college and the
university or colleges in the university
are not necessarily warm in terms of the
relationships all the time but here is
some of our college which
is Britain's first or women's colleges
now it's no longer so but it has that
history and this empty site here is
called the Radcliffe infirmary it was
the major National Health Service
Hospital at the centre of Oxford until
the university bought the site it was
the biggest acquisition they had had for
200 years in a very substantial
development that was master plan by
Rafael viñoly and there are a number of
buildings being built on the site at the
moment there's a school of government
here by Hertzog de mer on the vignola
mathematics Institute has been built
these eighteenth-century listed
buildings are being refurbished and we
won a competition to design student
accommodation which round from this
street Woodstock Road down to this
street Walton Street which is got Oxford
University Press at the end it was an
extraordinary sight and breathe because
you can see the huge blank wall where
they took all the old hospital buildings
away and so this kind of health and dust
real complex was destroyed leaving the
blank flank walls of Somerville College
and really what the university wanted
was Somerville College to provide a sort
of been acceptable facade to this edge
of the site so that they could develop
the rest of the quarter and Somerville
College in a quid pro quo were seeded
six metres of land which is about from
here to the wall and not much more in
which they could put the depth of one
student room and a corridor which is
about two thirds of a mile long linking
all of those together and there was no
way they could enter the building from
this site because it's University land
and we did a plan which looked at how
they might deal with that and the first
thing we saw and this opportunity was a
possibility they're given a building
that long and that narrow it should at
least be conceived of as one side of a
street and so you can see what we had in
terms of the spatial arrangement the old
wall of Somerville College room for a
passageway and room for one route for
one student room looking out to a pure
north orientation and what we chose to
do is to say that in every place that we
could find courtyards or openings or
light wells in the college we would open
into those to ameliorate the regret the
oppressive quality of the long corridor
we would make the communal facilities
into windows through which you could see
out onto the street
but we would frame each building at the
end with stair towers which
used a sort of markers in the street and
we were particularly interested in
pevsner's analysis of Queens Lane and
Oxford where he talked about an episodic
or picturesque quality to the gradual
development of a medieval city like
Oxford and what he was particularly
interested in was the sense of the kind
of views that you get that there's never
a very long view the viñoly master plan
was strongly bows are on its arrangement
very strong axial character to it and
what we argued was that that was not the
sort of spatial character of the rest of
the city what we tried to do is to use
this building here to set up another
spatial experience so standing on the
Woodstock Road and looking in this
direction your review is closed by the
first stair tower when you get to that
stair tower we got consent to separate
these two buildings here and make a view
through to a fountain and the square
then you do a little left and you look
down and we've asked that the architect
of that building will make a point of
interest in the facade which closes that
view then coming here to a view into
Gardens between ving yoli's building on
the 18th century building opening up on
this side into the quadrangle of
Somerville College making a gap between
these two historic buildings which will
give you a view from the inside of the
quad and Somerville out to a grade 1
listed building which is the right cliff
observatory which is visible in the
distance and when the street does a
little kink what we use is the two stair
towers at this end become Pepper Potts
which frame the axial view of the
observatory and then when the street
does a little kink you see all the way
down to this the gable of this listed
building here and as you make your way
down towards walk or towards what you
think closes that view you enter into
another square per dr. Murad's building
is here and you find yourself on access
with the neoclassical Oxford University
Press so it's a way of trying to use
this very long slender building to
stitch all of these incidents and events
together and to create this sense of a
continually unfolding streetscape and so
we worked continuing with models that's
the same view looking from the Woodstock
Road towards those stair towers the
Vignelli building the two Pepperpot
stair towers and so on we made a large
model of this street to try and explore
the views that you would get through
that and to understand the way which
those views open out into a much broader
understanding of the quarter so all of
the red buildings here
buildings that have a kind of a positive
sort of figure significance they the
beautiful turret of the observatory seen
from our street opening up that view
from the gardens this is our street
running through the quarter here and try
to understand it as something that will
stitch the existing established bit of
city into what will be a new bit of city
as yet on built and these are just the
details of the model looking at the way
in which those small closures are made
with little pocket squares on the way
down it's interesting to design a
building which in a sense will not be
complete for 20 years because it's like
one hand clapping you have just as one
side of the street and you're waiting
for other people to come along and
patiently hoping that they will
reciprocate in relation to the plans
that you've put forward but these are
the kind of views that we're talking
about our building on the right hand
side the vignola building just coming
into your view and beyond that the 18th
century infirmary building these are the
Pepperpot staircases and then this is a
photograph of these staircases seen
together and what we wanted to do is to
make very simple windows suggesting each
student room and then to turn the
staircases into lanterns with very deep
timber fins on them so this is a sketch
looking from the mathematical Institute
towards our building and then that's the
reality looking through at the gap
that's just been opened up to give you
the view the street itself is not
complete as you can see from the
construction equipment lying around we
have to wait until probably about 2018
before that's put into place and then
the the the lanterns themselves with
these very deep almost half meter deep
timber fins so that when you're walking
down the street you see right up into
the lantern but when you're looking at
it obliquely you see only timber the
window itself was designed with great
care the tradition in Oxford is that the
window itself represents the individual
student and we wanted to make something
from which they could look out of their
own room and into other people's rooms
the bay window was carefully considered
as a place that you could sit in and
work but also a seat which you could
perch in and and look along the length
of the street getting a little bit of
east-west light into each room so this
is an idea of what what one window would
be like looking towards the beautiful
observatory building in the
in the background and then the windows
from the outside form a kind of an array
a simple array of cubic objects really
pushing the depth of the Timbers of the
depth of the reveal is giving you this
deeply recessed window so you can be
sitting in your window seat feeling that
you're projected out from the room but
but protected by your projected out but
protected by the reveals of the window
as you as you look out onto the street
and then from the inside of the college
you get the sense of the D the opacity
of the staircases when you see them
obliquely but when you look straight
about them that the reveals and the
underside of the precast era forms a
kind of a marker in the streetscape that
gives you a sense of the lantern and
light quality that we wanted to have
it's something of a difficulty because
this street will be mostly academic
officers on the other side so we wanted
to make sure that the illumination of
the interiors will be the thing that
brings light to the life to the streets
and so each of the staircases has an
elaborate kind of softer to the ceiling
which will give you a sense of a marker
that as you walk by these these four
four lanterns will be uplift as you walk
along the street the next project is
altogether different in that what we
were talking about here was entering
into an established bit of city which is
its own very strong history and a
relationship between built for months
and sort of social and political ideas
the second one is almost completely
different or this next one is almost
completely different and that it's a
project that we were asked to do which
is a very unusual Commission this is the
site it's a piece of completely cleared
ground this is about 2010 and it was for
the London Olympics and it's an
extraordinary proposition really that
apart from the iconic projects which you
probably know the athletes village was
disposed of are procured in a way which
I find fascinating in terms of the
abstraction of the way in which
construction is sometimes going the
government wanted to build a completely
new piece of city in what had been a
vacant industrial site in the Lee Valley
they didn't want to take the
construction risk themselves but because
it was the Olympics they wanted to
ensure cultural values because it was
representing Britain in some way so they
came up with what I call the sort of
three-legged race which is the kind of
combining of the
the motive power of capital was the sort
of trembling of that power through
legislation and through committees and
so on which you which you get is a way
of developing and controlling bills form
and you can make a new piece of City by
using that capital as the engine for
development but then you impose values
on that development through kind of
legislation rhetoric design committees
and so on and so the whole of this
project was procured in this way and it
produced a very abstract thing where the
site was completely cleared and the
building which I worked on was designed
by at least six different architectural
teams and the master plan by two and
they realized that if you're going to
design housing for athletes it's much
better to design housing which would
become building stock for the long term
in the city and simply to re-engineer it
backward for athletes because they'd
only be in it for six weeks but they had
books this thick from the registered
social landlords in London who would
eventually take over the buildings with
their space standards and imposed it on
on top of them the space standards of
the International Olympic Committee and
lend lease who were the developer said
well we're not going to get lots of
different architects doing that the
government said that they had to get the
sort of pick of the 20 young practices
in the country to design a building each
and the whole thing was hammered out
between them the two of the most
commercial of the 20 M architects would
design all of the housing on the site in
terms of its core form its spatial
organization and then the others will be
given the opportunity to provide a
facade for these houses following rules
which were laid down by a committee of
the great and the good and it seems to
me that this rather extraordinary
arrangement has something about it which
is absolutely true to the abstraction of
the way in which buildings are brought
about in this way and while some
architects thought it was a bad idea to
do it I thought being a visitor at the
country I could hardly turn down the
opportunity to represent them in the
Olympics and secondly that it presented
a unique kind of problem which is what
happens when the arc of the values that
architects often hold about winning the
materials from the land and making it
from the hands of the craftsmen what
happens when you reach the extreme
opposite of that in terms of abstraction
this is a master plan of the site and
we're the little red box to element
there most of this site was not built
but all of the architects who are
working on it were working around around
this square it's an amazingly isolated
site lend-lease had bought up at
Westfield and lend-lease had bought up
the site before the Olympics and it's a
very isolated piece of land at Glen
Howells who was one of the commercial
architects asked us to design the green
building you can see at the top of this
image and I say the facade for the
building and what we did is we
absolutely refused to discuss the
interior of the building at all we
simply took the grid of the rooms as
they came out and made a building out of
that and it was key to our thinking that
we would make what we our project was an
independent facade for this building and
in a way we were looking for a way to
think about this facade that would
represent some of the kind of dilemma
that we were in as designers and I was
fascinated by Corbusier's interests in
Taylorism because it's one of those if
you sow the wind you'll reap the
whirlwind stories he was fascinated by
terrorism and wrote about it with great
enthusiasm but in Taylorism the idea was
that the the the world would be divided
between the makers who could be broken
down into the smallest and most
efficient particles of manufacture and
then the planners who would oversee the
makers and bring synthesis and
coordination to their to their work but
what Courvoisier didn't realize is that
if you can do that to maker is you can
also do it to architects and in this
process here the project manager becomes
the planner and then you have six
different architects working in silos
designing one building and so that sort
of breaking down and turning into small
discrete particles of the design process
is something that can that I would say
is as much a product of terrorism as
anything else but I was really
fascinated by Corbusier's insistence on
the Parthenon as being a kind of an
ancient equivalent to the DeLarge
motorcar that each of the pieces of the
Parthenon is perfected in itself brought
to a peak of perfection and then
assembled into a piece of synthesis by
this great single mind and clearly
Corbusier is thinking of himself as that
single mind and I I was I was I was I
was fascinated by that contrast but also
the invitation that the Parthenon might
be an abstract thing and I'd always
loved the Parthenon stones and
to me I'll come back to them in a moment
but they seem to me to be some of the
most abstracted and lost and let's say
deracinated are rootless things that one
can think of and so falling back on that
issue of architectural representation I
began to look at semper as ideas about
the relationship between a building as
constituting a static form at the center
which is what holds it up which is which
is one thing the idea itself the idea of
that form and finally what he would call
comfort form which is an art form or a
representative form and he sees the
external facade of the building as being
something that must embody two ideas one
of them is a hidden structural logic and
the other one is some parable about the
society that created it and of course
this falls back on Mies van der Rohe his
column in the in the in India in the
lakeshore drive apartments because from
Mies a who came from the tradition of
semper the idea that the steel on the
outside is a representation of a
concealed static work that's being done
on the inside would not be problematic
in the way that it would be to the
children of pujan but here are the
Parthenon stones themselves and what I
love about them is their abstraction the
idea that they once were or a garland
around the cult site of a God that they
were under the eaves of a temple they
were they were made to be seen and
reflected like coming off the ground
they were made per for particular
processions where as you walk past them
the narrative of the procession and the
frieze would unfold the the the spatial
illusion which if you study it is that
the is that the the horses in the
procession marching through the frieze
are actually marching through the depth
of the building and the way in which the
the meaning of it unfolds as you process
pastored and then they suffer the most
extraordinary range of depredations
they're burnt in a fire and 200 BC
they're mutilated by Christians and
they're it's used as a garrison by the
Turks and bombarded by Morosini the
Venetian the building explodes and Lord
Allegan comes and takes him away when he
takes him away he doesn't simply take
the stones off but he cuts the he turns
the stones from walling stones into
veneers so they lose all of their static
are
tecktonik logic and when he takes them
away they're sunk in a ship that's
taking them to London and they have to
be recovered by divers off Cape Sounion
and when they're brought to London
they're installed in the most polluted
city ever in the history of the earth
and allowed to gather a good coating of
sulfur dioxide from the coal fires that
were used to temper the room and until
they reached this absolutely beautiful
destroyed State and what I love about it
is that as people like vinkle man and so
on are constantly reaiiy d lysing the
stones they're being mutilated more and
more and damaged more and more and of
course the greatest damage they do is
when Duveen tries to clean them in 1939
and takes the face off the stones and so
this relationship between their physical
depredation and they're constantly
idealization and the idea they become
from from from cult objects they become
kind of artworks and that they get
copied and duplicated all the time I see
them even in this building that they go
around the world so they become
ubiquitous and lost at the same time and
to me the abstraction and AB rootedness
of the condition is something that I
wanted to express and of course in
London they become reproduced in all
sorts of ways here in code stone as a
kind of decoration to the new housing
for the fur therefore for the new middle
classes and I was interested in this
thing that Andy Warhol says about images
that if you reproduce them often enough
you produce a kind of numbness and I
thought there will be an interesting
thing to try and produce in a building
this is a sense of an endless repetition
and a kind of numbness and also this
beautiful image by Sol LeWitt where the
idea the idea of the endless repetition
of one form producing a kind of parallel
form to endless empty thinking and so
the kind of hypnotic almost in contato
equality of these two images is
something that I wanted to apply to the
stones so we were able to afford to to
use five panels of the stones and to cut
them into five further panels which gave
us 25 different panels and what we did
I'll talk about how we how we use the
stones in a moment but what we did was
we made these drawings here which were
given to the project managers and
quantity surveyors and I said what
you'll try and do is value engineer this
building and what we will do is we
absolutely won't stop you this is a
score or an algorithm by which you can
value engineer the bill
and as long as you obey the rules of
this you can make the building as
cheaply as you like all you do is change
properties of the casts that we're
making and so using that we prepared a
facade weird into the museum at night
with the keeper of the stones you can
see the cleaner is in the security man
hanging around and we took these
three-dimensional digital photographs of
the stones and so using this scanning
system we were able to take take take
the stones and make accurate
three-dimensional digital models I had a
strong idea but the five stones I wanted
to scan but the keeper of the stones
came in at about four o'clock in the
morning and he said Neal the people of
London will love the horses just give
them the horses and I thought well the
horses would be great so we changed
overnight to the stones that we would we
I thought they'll make a kind of a lost
troop so we will overnight we changed
and scan the horses and you can see what
we do here is to pass a grid over them
and photograph it constantly as it
changes and that produces a
three-dimensional digital file and then
we did this incredible cheat where we
brought the digital file back to the
office and we took all the opéra
surfaces and just lifted them up like
this so frost couldn't get caught behind
them so they look exactly the same but
you can't see that all of the crevices
behind the stones have been digitally
altered and I was amused in the office
that there's a kind of a baroque excess
you see in most buildings that are
digitally produced and I liked this the
idea that we would make a building that
was digitally produced that was quite
different from that accepted type so
here we are using the files to to cut
out meat medium density board positives
and those positives you can see a
finished one here are very carefully
glued together
it's extraordinary if you look at this
image here that this is damaged onto the
stone in 200 BC from the fire which has
been accurately digitally transmitted
onto the medium density board and then
cast into latex and eventually made into
precast panels and a really enjoyable
day and my architectural career was
going to the flat Fenland of
Lincolnshire where they had this factory
and seeing this ghost army of 400 horses
in precast concrete marching across the
misty fens in winter and it was
interesting that in the middle of all of
this and this is the three-legged race
at work they'd put a panel together of
the Great and the good which constituted
all the matter that the the project
managers from lend-lease and all
these kind of architects of a certain
sort of status in in in in London who
would sit in judgment on the 25 schemes
that were being produced and I came in
and discussed my scheme in detail and I
said the most important thing about it
was that all of these panels will be
randomly distributed within a completely
even grid and somebody had decided that
would unite all the buildings on the
site was that they would have a base
middle on top and as long as you had a
base middle and top you passed muster
and there was a long discussion at the
crit where I was saying that
conceptually ours couldn't have a base
middle on top because it's important
that they would be in a grid like array
and so the panel were saying well could
you have a bit of a base middle on top
I'm saying well it's not a question of
how much of it you have but a more of a
conceptual thing this went on for about
five minutes which was the value side of
the conversation and after five minutes
the project manager went you base middle
top
Mandy or I'll do it myself so
so I went back to the office everyone
was dismayed and I said it's absolutely
fine we'll have a base middle top on
Monday because we got a value
engineering meeting on Wednesday and
we'd be back to where we were by Friday
which is how it turned out but what I
love about these images here and
particularly say this one looking back
it's Emperors idea that the the facade
is the facade is something that
represents the hidden logic of the
building here we have one precast panel
which is one beam one column another bit
of a beam and an infill panel and
they're all one thing and they're there
pert they're presented to the building
so I really enjoyed this image and also
what we did was to digitally set 0 as
being the structure and that everything
in the cast is then positive of 0 so
they develop a kind of a rugged quality
you can see the structure here as being
the zero plane and everything projects
out from that and you can see the way
that they then run along the building
what we did was we found the most random
process we could discover which has got
something for about raised from space
completely random process and we use
that to allocate the panels of the
facade so there's no compositional
intention whatsoever I have to say I
slightly preferred the building when it
was not not fully glazed it felt it had
the sense of being a free-standing
screen and this image here I took I
liked it I thought that Leong career
would like it because of the curtains
blowing and the wind it has a certain
kind of moment that polythene bags
blowing in the wind but this was a sense
of what the building would be as a kind
of an independent freestanding screen
the facade the faces the square had
balconies and we can see it here it's
interesting that the main Greek
newspaper had an article in it which
said this architect is in league with
Satan and it was a two-page spread but
then being Greeks they said but maybe
he's a Helena file maybe he's in league
with Satan maybe he's a runner file but
eventually the Greeks came and stayed in
this building so they can't have been
that distressed word and so this is the
sense of the balconies facing onto the
square the the next project I want to
show you is it almost is a really deep
historic context it's an extraordinary
site and a rather amazing client these
paintings here were painted by zurbarán
the great Spanish painter in the 17th
century contemporary of Velazquez and
going
and just at the time of the Spanish
Inquisition and the expulsion of the
Jews from Spain he painted the the the
the the sons of Jacob so a
characterization of all the tribes of
Israel
it's not clear why he did it or who he
did it for but they were sent to Brazil
in a treasure ship and disappeared from
history probably in the Caribbean
somewhere to rhea merge a hundred and
fifty years later in an auction house in
London and the Bishop of Durham bought
them and at the time he bought them he
wants to put them in his dining room and
because he was polemically trying to
agitate for the naturalization of Jews
and the for Catholics feared how to
practice their faith and he saw these as
being powerful emblems of his liberal
attitudes and so they've been in that
room since recently when the bishops
wanted to sell the paintings and a
private client bought the paintings for
20 million pounds on condition that he
could also buy the castle which has been
in the hands of the bishops since the
Norman conquests about 900 our thousand
years ago and and so what he's done is
to take this castle which you can see in
the right hand side of the image here to
restore it as a visitor attraction he's
living in the lodge of the castle
himself he's building a museum called
5,000 years of faith
he's building a branch of the Prado
Museum in Madrid which is going to be a
Museum of counter-reformation art and
he's building a hotel and he wants to
turn this kind of down on its luck
mining town into a visitor attraction in
the northeast of England based on
religious faith and he's quite
interested in he said he wants people to
come to this and if they have deep faith
he wants them to be troubled by it and
if they have no faith he wants them to
be troubled by it and he's going to make
this broad visitor attraction we won the
competition for the master plan and
there are now various architects working
on the site and just looking at this
aerial photograph one thing about the
site is it's on an escarpment the castle
was built in the 10th century on an
escarpment which overlooks the river
weir and you can see here the old Roman
work Road up to Durham which goes right
through the town
turns right around the where and there
was a roman fort built here from which
many of the surrounding buildings were
built and this site was first built on
in about the 10th century and they've
built on it every century since then the
bishops were armed because the north was
very rebellious and they were called
prince-bishops they're an extraordinary
mixture of Fathers of the Church and
sort of medieval condottieri keeping the
Scots at bay and keeping the rebellious
English down it was a great mixture a
sort of martial prowess and religious
fervor you can see the lovely setting of
the site looking at this theater of
woodland across the valley from the
escarpment the 10th century dining hall
of Bishop Beck which is now a chapel and
the 18th century Robinson archway which
shows the development of the castle into
this kind of genteel neo-gothic which
many of you would know from the city
around here and so the initial kind of
martial power of this site was slowly
transformed into a kind of polite
architecture here are the bishops in
their throne room over time and this is
the setting of the town and what I was
really fascinated by was if we look at
this last slide for a moment is that as
a relationship between the bishops and
the people becomes more democratic the
images of the castle changed from this
angle around to this angle so the town
is initially something stuck out the
back of the castle and as time goes on
the town is something the castle is
something which is appended to the town
and that sense of the democratization of
religious power was really palpable in
the images so we can see here the castle
as an escarpment with the town lingering
in the background as an 18th century
Park with the town more or less
invisible the first images in the late
18th century shows people arriving from
the parkland with the town separated
from them by the Robinson archway and
then for the first time in the late 19th
century we see people on fete in the
landscape with the castle in the
background but we've now rotated through
90 degrees and finally we're seeing in
the 20th century from the town the first
ever image of the castle from the town
is this postcard what we wanted to do is
try and link the castle on the town
together in some profound way and to
make a kind of a parade that links the
town square and the castle and that was
our first plan and what we would do then
is look at all the layers of history
which are perhaps too complex for this
lecture and
thousand to see what we might put new
buildings at the two buildings which
we're designing here in the master plan
are the museum building which is an
extension of the castle and a new
welcome building here then son are
designing some pavilions in the garden
and other architects are being appointed
under the master plan as we speak
and so the castle itself becomes a
sequence of routes through gardens and
you can see here the way that that might
be different gardens relating to
different ages this is a quick look at
the sound scheme which will be a kind of
lots of bucky balls in the garden it's
got a way to go one would say and then
no I mean I mean that in terms of its
technical development rather than design
terms but I think that is something that
was our first sketch scheme and you can
see the two buildings and darker images
here and one of the buildings we have to
do was the museum building and I'll
speak about that briefly first it sits
in the position of the old Granger farm
which was part of the castle and we
wondered what kind of this is a
protected ancient monument what kind of
stone architecture you could put here
and what fascinated me was the idea that
we could put a long barn like building
here and create a new garden but there's
this alleyway here and that this
building here might have a kind of
primitive form but what I was really
interested in was that how do you make a
building which is a museum which deals
with issues of the sacred are issues of
faith but is not itself a church the
plan of it's very simple arriving out of
the castle through a sequence of rooms
that deal with time pilgrimage other
issues monasticism other issues of
religion this part of the castle here is
all about paganism and you come up to
the top and it's the Reformation you
walk back through the religious disputes
of the 17th and 18th century and finally
you're looking at contemporary Britain
with all of the multitude of religions
in it and at the top of the stairs here
there's a staircase that looks down over
the garden and then this is one long
kind of Hall which is got exhibits in it
very simple plan you can see the section
of that looking over the gardens beneath
and the escarpment in the landscape and
one thing I wanted to do is to look at
these quite primitive building forms
this is a crock swell barn from the 13th
century and I absolutely love the sort
of stone enos of it and it's sort of
it's it's sort of certainty that englidh
like quality that I spoke about earlier
but I was fascinated by the way the
Basilica which is a secular building
when it turned into Christian churches
did so by adopting certain aspects of
Roman temples I was interested in the
primitive quality we'd used here before
and this building which I showed you in
the West of Ireland this building to me
is absolutely fascinating the more I
looked into it because the stone
building which has these things called
ante which are forward projections which
they used to turn basilica's into sacred
buildings by alluding to the Pro næss of
the Roman temple now this was seen by
monks in Canterbury in a church in
Ravenna in the fourth century and they
copied it in Canterbury in in the brick
building they copied in stone Irish
monks saw the brick building and came to
this island and built a timber version
of it and this forward projection here
is the ante turned into what must be a
skew morph of timber construction the
cross rafters at the top and it's
fascinating that this skew morph here
where the cross rafters which would have
been a practical constructional detail
then becomes a symbol of the figure of
Christ the reason I find this
fascinating in an eighth century Irish
building is that if you look at this 8th
century Japanese building you get the
exact same thing for the cross rafters
at the top which are called chichi and
become emblems of the Sun God the
divinity which you see in the ESA shrine
and that way in which practical
constructional details get turned into
symbolic emblems and then get carried
forward beyond their practical use and
the way that further to that in some
cases they then get turned from one
material to another and retained as
remnants of an older form of
construction that sense of the
transformation of origins is something
that really fascinates me so we decided
what we would do with our big barn
building was to put an ante and to
and-and-and-and a projection forward in
stone of a previous timber construction
you can see the way that we've done it
here we should have an incredibly
lightweight structure on the inside and
then this stone roof on the out
I'd create creating a very simple form
these are the details are currently
working through with the Masons to
create the crop the stone skew morph of
cross rafters at the top of the building
and then this is an image of what the
building would be like projecting onto
the parade looking along the line of the
castle and so the sacred sense of that
is given by the projection forward of
the stone Pro order of the stone ante
and the crossing of the rafters to
suggest the way in which constructional
details come become emblems of divinity
and this is the beautiful stone they
have on the site and how it whether is
an iron stone that's the position that
will be in that gives you some sense of
it and then the interior is extremely
lightweight structure on the inside we
sort of defies the idea that you're
inside the same stone ingot at the other
building which is the welcome building
on the site we wanted to be it's on this
interesting corner site and we found
this emblem of the 15th century drawing
of a tower which had been on the site
and tried to persuade English heritage
that we should build a tower and those
very strongly heritage sites it's
extremely difficult to do anything
unusual and the first thing they said to
us is you will not put a tower on this
site but in a year of negotiation bit by
bit we persuaded to build them to build
a 30 metre high tower on the site but
was interesting about it was the
transformation of that through
discussion with the people of English
heritage and a full understanding of the
history of the castle so we worked on
these models looking at the town scape
and bringing it up to English Heritage
in the north this is the for senior
people from English heritage looking at
our tower I like the image because in
the background in the picture there's a
lovely company lay on this picture here
and the the idea that you could build a
tower that looks over this whole
landscape and allows you to understand
it the debate became that the tower was
too defensive and so we showed drawings
of viola viola le Dukes siege engines
from his a treatise on medieval
architecture and said rather than the
tower being something which looks out
from the castle it could be a sort of
fantasy of of siege and based on that we
brought these emblems up this is a
meeting we had with English Heritage
with 12 versions of the tower and model
form each one of which was attempted to
sort of beseech their idea that they
couldn't have a tower and each one which
fell by the wayside and so the end of
the meeting I just thought that was a
good kind of
image of the way in which the project
had gone but eventually we settled on
this tower which would overlook the site
the plan is very simple you arrive in
from the town square under the tower you
enter into ticketing and shop you go up
the staircase and there's a room
upstairs which is about interpreting the
landscape and the history of the
landscape then you go on up the tower
and look out over the landscape there's
a courtyard flanked by toilets here
which has got a decorative pavement in
the center of it and so this is a sense
of what the tower will be like and I was
fascinated by the idea of the building
rather than containing interpretation
could itself be an interpretive
structure and so everything that you
need to know about the history of the
site would be written in the walls of
the building
and I love these old these are all old
images of timber buildings that are no
longer here which have been preserved
either in books or caskets and we wanted
to use some of these qualities in the
building it's a very simple section with
north light coming in here and these
shutters which open up with the tall
tower beside it and the Robinson arch in
the background I like the kind of
heraldry that you get within the castle
and we wanted to use some of that in the
way in which the architecture was made
and so it's a very simple building with
wooden shutters which are closed and
when the castle opens they open and when
they open up this is a building we've
just finished which shows you how that
will be done with automated panels which
just open the whole building up so it
becomes a completely open framework and
then we wanted to borrow the kind of
graphic language of these books of ours
these are the tray readers to show a
kind of a history of the development of
a landscape and that those will be put
onto the building so it becomes like a
piece of heraldry when the building has
opened up and looking at the Bruce Lee
Bruce library with the text on the base
of it and these open sections overhead
we've taken the same detail here for all
the written information about the site
is on the base and the panels hang above
that in a fairly simple fashion and they
automatically open up and then it's an
old mining town these old pieces of
mining equipment gave us our sort of
tectonic language and this is a sense of
the tower itself which you ascend to
give you a view across the landscape an
image of what the building would be like
you can see the Scotland doing there in
the background
the viewing the viewing tower up here we
wanted it to be a sort of playful
structure with balconies that come off
at each different level so that kids can
kind of hang out there on the way up and
this gives you a sense of what the what
the scale of the tower this is the
medieval wall of a castle here right up
against it the the the the tower itself
is a very simple sort of timber
structure with metal inside it and as
you make your way up through it the
views extend and unfold until you're at
the top we did this great thing with
English heritage of getting a cherry
picker and standing up there to see what
you could see this gives you a sense of
the views right across the Roman fort at
Ben Chester and then looking down onto
the map of the landscape below which is
done on a paved pattern like a mosaic
pattern on the floor I love that sense
that you get medieval cathedrals that
often the floor as a map of the world
which you can look down on from the
upper galleries and towers of the
Cathedral the last project I want to
speak about this evening is a chapel
that we designed in the centre of
England absolutely beautiful site with
arts and crafts buildings by GE Street
gathered around the perimeter the
biggest and oldest beech tree in England
it's from 1711 and this lovely round of
trees here the ground falls very steeply
to the valley at Garlington beneath and
then up the far side so you're looking
out into this valley and then this
pristine site the site for the chapel
was given and there's a future nunnery
for some religious sisters which is
going to be here the sister is in great
sort of old-fashioned way we're moving
into the Theological College and brought
the chapel as a gift competition you can
see the image of the chapel here and the
kind of arts and crafts buildings we
have the local people and the students
call it holy Hogwarts and that's the
kind of quality that it has at sort of
oxford arts and crafts gothic we did the
competition interview we had this idea
of the boat and I'll read you the poem
by Seamus Heaney because I think it's
very beautiful where he says the monks
have come on like noise are all at
prayers inside the oratory and a ship
appeared above them in the air the
anchor dragged along behind so deep it
hooked itself into the altar rails and
then as a big hole rock to a standstill
a crewman shimmed shinned and grappled
the rope and struggled to release it but
in vain this man can't bear our life
down here and we'll drown the abbot said
unless we help them so they did the
freed ship sailed and the man climbed
back out of the marvellous as he had
known it what I love about this is the
hidden or missing word in the poem his
nave the Latin word for the body of a
church or for a ship and we we use the
word nave in the competition to start to
speak about nave as the still point of a
wheel for a theological students going
out in the world that seemed to be a
beautiful image the idea of a floating
airship or a ship in the air we said we
wanted the building to have the quality
of a kite flyer that you stood with your
feet glued to the ground but feeling as
though you might be lifted off it and
the first image we made was of making a
simple mark in the ground on the brow of
the hill which would sit under the tree
with the sacred space made within that
mark in space for the community to
gather under the beech tree and then
that the trees around it could be
conceived of as creating a clearing and
the structure might replicate that
clearing to give you an outer world
beyond the clearing and an inner world
made by the structure and then the idea
of the ship in the air as being like a
ship of souls or the disciples on the
ship on the Sea of Galilee and the
community of the faithful beneath them
and we said we wanted there to be a
spatial quality which would be like
being on the deck of the ship and being
beneath the ship at the same time if we
could try and get that spatial character
into the building and then this simple
sketch done in the competition of our
clearing in a thicket a way of looking
into the light
they had Astra what's called a collegial
or an antiphonal Chapel which is where
they pray back and forth to each other
you see it in all of the Cambridge and
Oxford colleges and as they were talking
about it antiphonal is when you pray
from one side to the other as they were
talking about it as a competition
briefing I noticed that the the hands of
a guy who was describing it starts to
creep in like that and he said but we
want a greater sense of community this
is new college chapel which is a classic
antiphonal chapel so we use this image
in the competition and said well we
could create a greater sense of
community by bending in the edge like
that and since you've gone that way you
might as well go the whole hog and
create an ellipse and when you've made
an ellipse it's a really fascinating
form because both geometrically in terms
of theological ideas but
architecture II it's got such a potent
history and within the ellipse we could
say that the site for the Liturgy of the
Eucharist the blessing of the bread
would be one point of the ellipse and
the place for the Liturgy of the word
which is the reading of the Gospels will
be the other point of the ellipse and we
were fascinated by this notion that the
ellipse is is is in in terms of theology
as seen as being perfection reached
through imperfection and in that sense
it's got a very strong relationship and
theological terms with the notion of
Incarnation that the circle represents
God and his totality the son is the
emblem of God but Kepler saw the the
orbits of the planets as being an
embodiment of the relationship between
form and force that man who walks a line
and God who's perfect and endless come
together in the image of the ellipse
which is the relationship between
perfect geometry and linear force and so
we began to look at these plans which
were all versions of of elliptical forms
and the one we were particularly
fascinated by was Rudolf Schwartz as
plan for some Michaels in Frankfurt and
the beautiful variation of that which he
resumed toward is at the church a placin
percent benedict and analyzing the
geometry of that looking at the
elliptical form and understanding how it
works and what's interesting about this
is that a schwartz in cinema said
michaels puts the structure deliberately
just outside the walls of the ellipse
and then sumter when he doesn't Benedict
puts it deliberately just inside the
walls of the ellipse and our idea was we
would make a further move and bring them
in by the width of an ambulatory this is
Schwartz's church here with a beautiful
clear story in the elliptical form and
the the interior which is in in the
sense robbed of its structure and given
a kind of a weightlessness so working
through the elliptical platforms we came
up with this idea of an oven of an
elliptical ambulatory just wide enough
to walk around the whole chapel and the
timber structure on the inside the
clerestory window would bring light in
between the Keele like roof and the
structure which holds up that roof all
of the vertical loads of the roof are
taken out by the structure all of the
horizontal loads are taken out by these
Spurs which connect the structure back
to the ellipse and
that gives you your form and within that
there's an elliptical enclosure which
contains the seating so it's a that was
the idea in section that the building is
illuminated by hidden light behind the
structure and then the elliptical form
allows you to make a perfect space on
the inside with the altar and that and
the lectern here surrounded by seats the
ring of the structure and the ambulatory
around the outside and the ambit
realized difference to occur so you get
the tabernacle a view out towards
Garlington and the sisterís prayer room
the sacristy everything which is
different is allowed to be different by
that buffer zone of the ambulatory I'll
finish off the lecture by giving you a
shortish worhty and reading of this but
just to speak a little bit about the way
we worked on it working with models and
this is Mariah the project architect
listening to an acoustic model of the
chapel while she looks into it and the
idea that you could conceive of both
read both the light coming through the
windows the space itself and listen to
the acoustic of it as you're designing
it we had great fun then with the
clients bringing that out onto site and
helping them to understand its position
among the trees and the drawing then of
what the chapel would be like and we
wanted to have this white wall behind
the structure which you get this endless
play of this sort of skipping rope of
light which moves around all the time
just to take a pause at the end of
designing this building between design
and construction we were asked by John
to me at UCD to come and do a lecture
and make a little project there so I was
fascinated by Peters ultras description
of medieval Masons pouring plaster of
Paris onto the floors of the chapels and
drawing the stone jigs on the floor so
we asked some builders to pour lime
plaster onto the floor of this Georgian
room in the School of Architecture in
Dublin and then the whole project team
from the office came over and with three
students we thought we would set up the
ellipse ourselves so it was an activity
of drawing together and when I'm
teaching at the moment I'm talking often
about the way in which you go about
doing things being what the building
becomes and this was really a process in
which we would just spend time as a
complete team who had designed the
building drawing it together for a week
talking about it and helping ourselves
to understand it before it goes to site
and I won't say much about it except
just to show you some images of the
drawing on the cast plaster floor as it
develops
the setting out of the ellipse
who's seen a flexi curve for a decade
and then finally the drawing on the
floor itself as I kind of completed as a
completed thing it was a very nice
moment where we finished the drawing and
then step straight into the lectern
which you see in the background and
delivered a lecture at the waiting
school and what was very nice about that
was the building was set out on site the
next week so here's our ellipse under
the great beech tree and setting out the
earthwork and in situ concrete and
building up the sidewalls making that
clearing within the trees and then the
ship in the air this lovely moment and
we talked about sometimes building sites
themselves being pieces of architecture
that are transient but they have a power
that the building itself will lose here
you can stand in the ship in the air and
look out towards Didcot and then the
keel is placed down on top of that you
get a really delicate moment of
connection when Seamus Heaney's airship
is there a visible in the construction
site for the first time and the sense of
a clearing and the trees the structure
making occurring of the trees and the
sort of thicket like quality we were
looking out from the construction side
and the sense of making making this
inner space well I want to do now is
just finish the lecture by going back to
Schwartz's idea because and there were
two aspects of this building that were
important in one sense and tectonic
terms that belongs to semper and his
four principles of architecture the
basis and earth work made from in situ
concrete the timber structure is the
independent frame the tabernacle is a
hearth and the walls are the veil that
separates it from the outer world but
Schwartz speaks really beautifully about
the ineffable about it the theological
ideas expressed in space and he talks
about God being like a star and he talks
about the eye as being the answer to a
star he said the darkness of the body
rises up and meets the light of the star
and the eye and forms an image and the
light current from the outside he said
the eye is not a star but rather answer
to it it is circumference dark hollow
and in readiness and he produces a plan
then when the image of the eye accepting
the star becomes the arrangement of the
people face in the altar in the chapel
and then he says the altars at once the
center and threshold earth and wall
world gather of the altar and they reach
their end on three sides it faces the
world and on the fourth it faces heaven
the spot where the world turned to face
eternity stays behind and from this spot
a sacred way begins
and he speaks beautifully about
structure there are three forms of cynic
Doge in his description one is the
building as an eye the other is
structure as being like the hand he said
that the structure
he said the hand is different from the
eye and that it knows the backs of
things it knows their three
dimensionality and it carries their
weight to the ground through lines so
it's a different form of knowing and he
associates that with structure and he
says it would be a one final step to
give up the fixed structural space
entirely and to use the structure simply
as a means of which to render in free
creation the ever-changing space this is
the structural model and the sense of
the structure as an enclosure that
creates a space for the community a
space for the nearby and therefore by
definition a space beyond that and he
says that there's a gaping hole in the
building a gap an absolute opening he
wants to build a gap in the structure
through which the space of the community
looks out towards eternity and there's a
lovely passage in his book the the
church in Corinth where he says what
could the representation of eternity be
he's as an image and a window to the
landscape and eventually he decides that
the only thing it could be is a blank
wall or garbs isolation of an eternity
is is expressed and he says it might be
best not to work out the image at all
but instead to leave the structure with
a rift in it and the open space would
simply remain empty a meaningful blank
in the ring this would be intimated by
leaving a part of the wall utterly white
not a termination but unlocking and an
opening and so the whole wall around the
outside of the structure is this white
surface to receive light from the
clerestory window and the last one is a
cynic dose of the year he's a beautiful
image of the mother reading to a child
but I think the thing that fascinates me
about reading and the biblical thing of
reading for a Protestant Church is that
you end up into a much a relationship
which is based much more on dialogue
people have read the Bible and they're
answering what they're hearing through
their own knowledge so we've made that
like an auditorium or the Sacred Way
opens out from the altar we close the
space which faces a lectern to give you
this sense of an amphitheater around the
lecture and so the openness towards
eternity which the altar faces is closed
when the air when the when the air and
the lecture and faces and so you get
this slight difference in the two ends
of the building
and bringing those things together the
hand the structure of the near buying
community we get this circumambient way
around the outside and this gives you a
sense of the space which is opened up in
between then from beneath the beech tree
you come in and the students who are low
church and more dedicated to the Bible
come in under the beech tree and are
presented with the Liturgy of the word
the door or under the beech tree which
is which presents them with a lecture
and the sisters coming in from the
convent who are much more devoted to the
Liturgy of the Eucharist are given a
view of the tabernacle when they come in
and this is their a prayer room where
they sit and face the altar the light
beneath it and then looking from the
prayer room out towards the tabernacle
which you'll see in the background and
when we went to zoom towards Chapel in
Switzerland it was a meter deep in snow
and we were locked out and we made her
way through the snow and got to the top
and realized you had to go back to the
village for a key so I sent a student
back and why he did it I bent down and
looked through the keyhole and when you
look through the keyhole you can just
see right at diagonally at the opposite
end of the church from the keyhole you
can see a tiny box here which is got an
icon in it so somebody had realized that
people would be waiting for the key and
I thought that what we would do is just
as a homage to that the way in which
this disrupts the the forum I thought
was really beautiful and so we would
make something which looks out towards
the landscape which disrupts the form in
the same way and so the two images
Nature has seen visibly as a view of the
landscape and nature as embodied in the
abstraction of the tabernacle or the
gold on the green side by side in this
image and they can become projections
out from the building so the tabernacle
gathers only pure north light and uses
it to hold the the metal element which
is Simpers material emblem of the hearth
and then the window itself projects out
like a kind of like a bowsprit from the
building to give you one little prayer
space which looks through a gap in the
trees towards Garson and then the the
belfry is at the point where the sisters
who are one community and the students
who are another community meet on axis
and this gives you a sense of the
position of the belfry joining the two
axes together we had a lovely time
because the Bell was a melting together
of the bells of the two communities in
the Whitechapel foundry they melted the
bronze of the two and made a new Bell
and then finally the sacred way from the
sacristy and we can
simple plain sacristy here and so
bringing together the CEMP Aryan idea of
the earthwork which is made from an in
situ concrete the timber frame the
keeled roof the woven tapestry Sempra
says that weaving is a motif for the
separation of the inner world from the
outer world and then the hearth of the
altar bringing that together with the
white wall and the sacred way opening up
from the gap of the structure the the
two figures of Schwartz and semper were
intended to be brought together in
different ways here so here's the woven
wall as stone bond which we sort of made
up by breaking and cutting the stone
alternately you can see the stone bond
here which takes up a form of the
ellipse
the independent tectonic frame and with
the light coming through
thank you so much for a beautiful talks
our beautifully presented I'm sure there
might be some questions for from our
audience from our students and faculty
are there some questions
all right we're bringing mic to you
thank you for the talk it's really
beautiful work you make it seem really
effortless and the way it's presented
which it's it totally believable at
least to me I'm wondering though if you
talked a little bit about the process is
there a struggle in that for you ever or
like how do you work through things
thinking about as a student like it's
sort of beautiful to think about all
these ideas how do they come together
for you in your mind I guess I think
that we try to make the process in a way
we try to introduce certain problematic
elements into it to try and find called
the project what the project could be
and I'm always afraid as an architect
that one works in a world of received
images and I'm concerned that to some
extent that architecture is that there's
a way in which architecture gets
produced for photographs and gets
produced out of photographs and that if
you are not careful about the way you
construct your design process that you
you kind of live in a world of you
produce your building from images and
you could use your building for images
and so a lot of the discussion that we
have in our office is how we can set up
ways of thinking about the project which
will allow us to create not necessarily
practical problems with conceptual
problems within the project and in
solving those that we're going to take
ourselves away from that world of
received images so a lot of our thinking
is about that
I don't design them individually at all
I always design with my staff and there
are about 60% people who I've taught and
and Yael will know that a lot of the
conversation we have is not about what
you're going to end up with but how
you're thinking about it as you go along
and how you conceive of the project as
you go along and to some extent the main
problem is often making space for
yourself in the office making space for
the group in the office to do that and
all of the reiterations of that requires
while maintaining the semblance of a
well-organized project the outside so
you can bring it through the kind of
client process and to some extent that's
what that's that's what the task is and
so it's certainly not easy and I think
one of the things that we've started
saying recently when were asked to enter
competitions or produce images of an
early stage that we simply can't and to
let that be a self-selecting process
that you work with those clients who are
prepared to accept that we turned down
the competition we won last week because
they said they needed a CGI and we said
well actually all the buildings that you
really like of ours couldn't have been
produced at this stage in the process
they like visually comes from a much
longer deliberation on the kind of the
fundamental ideas behind the project and
so making space for that is a problem in
a busy practice but we just wait for the
microphone please thank you man let's go
speed speed thank you very much Badman
did you find that your architectural
training wait a minute baby here okay
fire architectural training prepared you
to think theologically about your work
and what's the relationship between this
ecclesiastical work that you do and
everything else is it produced in much
the same sort of mode I I think when I
go back to use ideally to UCD there is a
slightly theological lift to UCD and I
think it probably comes from Louie
convey ashamed of blocking I can't think
of any other way it would have come the
school I was in was very founded in Mesa
and camp and there was a sense that
there was an unassailable there was
almost a divine and unsayable quality of
an architectural which isn't always
expressed explicitly in that way but I
think it was there and so the sense of
architecture are being a sacred thing
and the kind of almost priests like
quality of some of the people who taught
me is is it is it is in a way a kind of
preparation an interesting thing about
my education is that I went from
studying in UCD for seven years to
teaching and the Bartlett in London
which at the time had been taken over by
Peter Cook and you couldn't had a
greater change in the ethos in the
teaching ethos of two schools and so I
treated myself to a second education in
the in the Bartlett
which is a completely different way of
looking at the world in the sense that
UCD was founded almost entirely in the
Canon in precedent in the idea of
architecture being built in continuity
and from history while in the Bartlett
it was much more thrown back on an
individual invention and I remember John
to me saying you teach students how to
do things well and then if they're a
really brilliant they'll be brilliant in
their own terms and a couple of years
later here in Peter Cook saying you
teach students to be brilliant and then
they'll find boring people to do it for
them if they need it this is two
entirely different ways of looking of
the world and to some extent I've always
sort of balanced out those yeah I mean I
don't mean in those terms but the
Bartlett is so different in terms of its
in terms of his ethos to UCD he that
I've treated in a way as a second
education issues of the sacred I think
are perhaps closer in Irish culture than
they are on other cultures because it's
a recently very religious culture and so
the idea of the sacred is probably
closer to the surface in Ireland and
then than it is in
in some other cultures which is why I
suspect they were so amenable to recent
count hey I'm interested in your
attitude about craft I guess and and the
builders are the fabricators who you're
actually relying on in this and part of
that is relationship between you as a
designer and those people are actually
you know hammering that brick or or
whatever clearly there's not an attitude
about the honesty of material and
construction it's it's really more
almost a D familiarization of what the
materials are expected to do and what
you do to give us an awareness of that
but nevertheless there's a implicit
dialogue between the design and how it's
actually going to be produced by the
fabricator by the builder or by CNC you
know and so part of it is there's
clearly an attention to material but in
a non-traditional craft way and that's
then pushed I think particularly by your
willingness to you know just send the
digital files off to wherever when you
were doing the Olympic Village but I'm
just curious to know if there's a
particular attitude you have towards the
craft and the actual construction people
I mean I think it's a tragedy for a lot
of architects that the things that we
are most closely wedded to are clearly
not really achievable in the culture
that we live in so our attachment to
place the stability of the place truth
to materials truth to structure ideas of
the hammers have made it and craft
almost every architecture I know holds
those as deeply how beliefs but actually
they're I mean the stability of place is
highly questionable
a globalized culture of images and the
idea that you can make materials from
the material from make building some
material you win from the ground and the
hands of local people it simply doesn't
stack up with contemporary procurement
and so architects find themselves living
in a world which doesn't allow them too
many architects for himself in the world
doesn't allow them to stand up to
they're there they're there they're
there their deepest principles and I
think many of them see that as a
struggle without actually interrogating
it I think it's a particular problem for
architecture and and some of these
projects I've tried to in a sense stage
that problem are not to solve it because
I don't think it's a solvable problem I
think it's a paradox at the heart of
what we do and to some extent the the
project in the Athletes Village was
meant to be doing that it was meant to
be for me the personal stones are like
these emblems of modernity they're
completely separated from the place in
which they're made they become these
kind of globalized images and yet there
they are as stubborn things in the city
duplicated endlessly remade and so the
the idea of staging them and that kind
of hypnotic grid to me was a statement
not over the solution to that problem
but the that but but that that is a
thing that we can't resolve and I wanted
it to have that sense of paradox about
it that you couldn't quite get to the
end of that and I think that the use of
craft I think is generally highly
privileged if you are an architect in
the UK and you want to make primary
schools or hospitals or any of the
buildings of fundamentally serve society
you'll be doing it and through processes
of procurement that are so abstracted
and so broken down and where are the
values that you hold close are so little
regarded that it becomes in a way a kind
of a I was an impossible task but I
think it becomes a problem about
practice
I think the second paradox is the one
about the idea that buildings can tell
the truth it's something that almost
every architect I know in the UK
believes but I can't see how they can to
go back to Robin Walker's problem at the
Seagram or the lakeshore drive building
architecture is always representation
and even now physically when the outside
of a building is completely delaminated
it's interior the idea that an
architecture can be transparent or have
that truth-telling ability is something
that I think is not interrogated enough
by architects so to some extent all of
the project which I'm doing whether
they're carefully crafted or made in
very abstract processes or trying to
trying to be very equivocal and to stage
the paradoxical nature of those yes or
one could say that that nature of craft
is that abstracted one that those aren't
necessarily a dichotomy that there's
another notion of craft that actually
allows that abstraction to be its
aesthetic or in some way I mean I look
at this and you can't think that that's
not crafted on though I probably
imagined that that was cut out with a
laser cutter I mean I'm just trying to
say that you know they didn't you
describe it as a paradox but it it may
not be a contradiction so much but I
think the moment at which architects
went from a sort of Russ kinian notion
of the hands and the eye of the maker
into a fascination with machines and
technology and industrialized
manufacture what they've done is they've
transposed an older idea into a newer
medium but it's still the older idea
right it's still the notion that
buildings can somehow be true to
something deeper than themselves and I
think it's all semblance but the purpose
of architecture is creating the
semblance of truth but not actual truth
of transparency itself I I I was very
intrigued by how you looked at
Schwartz's diagrams in church incarnate
which are very abstract and I don't know
like taking something like that and
trying to achieve something ineffable
through that process was that something
that you knew about before and were
educated on or is that something that
was really an endeavour in this project
specifically and also did that maybe did
you reach some conclusions
buzzes I mean so many of the people who
I came across in this lecture who I've
mentioned were part of my pursuit of I
mean the the questions I think that Mies
asks in his architecture and the
difference between what he says and what
he does is to me a profound problem at
the heart of the way in which we
habitually conceived of say modern
architecture that this thing about truth
that our that the architecture in truth
while he comes so much from a tradition
of representation so in looking for that
I discovered many of the people who I've
mentioned here like Schwartz Mesa and
Schwartz were connected and I think
actually me throat the puffs on the back
of the church encourage you know best
book I've ever read me standard you know
going back to posture and temper that
there's a world which for me
conceptually unpicked those ideas that
all of those people belong to and if you
know that wonderful book on the best
books on architecture I've read which is
the artless word by by no amara which
picks through what Mies was reading when
he was designing his buildings and shows
you the conceptual background that he
was coming from and Mies and Schwartz
were linked by a guy called wardi II who
was a Jesuit priest and many of their
ideas are very very similar so there is
a world there that I was investigating
which is that that deep German history
which has got to do with representation
which goes back I think to German
idealism where is the question Tony are
you about to say something oh sure okay
all right then wait there's a question
in the back so in your projects you've
talked about the idea of truth and how
that relates to architecture and also
this idea of this extra natural or
supernatural in some ways but extra
natural experience that happens through
architecture do you think that these two
this notion of truth is directly related
to this a supernatural experience that
is evident in your architecture okay I'm
well I wouldn't I have no sort of see
illogical position at all I think I've
shown two sacred buildings and so you
might think that I'm a developer
architect making religious buildings but
if you're asked to make a building for a
religious community then that religious
community believe that the building
embodies a final truth and so your job
is to try and create a framework that
allows them to celebrate that final
truth through their communal worship
your own position as an architect is
neither here nor there in relation to
that what I'm trying to say all the time
is that in terms of time I don't think
that one should talk about the
truth-telling capacity of architecture I
think that the purpose of architecture
is to create the semblance of truth in
other words that when you come to a
building it appears to be so
harmoniously and logically put together
that you can read meaning into it
not that it's a stable container for
meaning and one of the other lecturers
that I would often give not this one is
about I particularly love buildings that
claim to tell the truth at one time and
when that truth fell away very quickly
for example we're working on the Natural
History Museum in London at the moment
and it was built as a complete essay
against Darwin and by the time it was
finished it was clear that all of the
ideas embodied in the design of the
building were wrong in the space of 10
years and one of the things about others
our architecture at the moment is that
our in our time is that those ideas of
stability of truths that can be embodied
in built form can't really exist in a
world where our images and ideas are
disputed constantly and where scientific
knowledge isn't is contingent you if
every representation of truth that you
put up will be replaced by another one
very quickly and so that's stability of
forms which equates to truth
isn't really a possibility in the
content in the context of say social
modernism or broad sense and it leaves
the architecture with a problem which is
that if you can't fulfill the central
vocation of architecture through history
which is to embody the idea of truth
then what do you do and I think that's
another one of those paradoxes that we
have to deal with that you have to you
have to try and you have to try and
create buildings which seem to which
seem to or which
point to some idea of truth and the
problems about transparency which have
got to do is truth to structure our
truths and materials truths to function
are because
buildings can no longer bear images
which are external representations of an
external truth they tend to fall back on
some notion of intrinsic truth
in other words if the world out there is
disputed the world within here contain
certainty so structure everything which
is within the building or within its own
terms can be expressed as the truth but
I think eventually that's equally
problematic and I think it's one of the
things that we have to do to show
buildings that appear to tell the truth
all the time while in fact not accepting
that is a stable truth that they can
tell and that's a kind of that's a
problem for architectures turning I knew
when I knew we get this it's a comment
more than a question it reminds me of
who at some point was very frustrated
when the Dominican priest was saying
this doesn't look like a monastery he
says he said something to the effect
that no no no I'm building a crop an
Acropolis which you are using as a
monastery just as I took your cell and
turned it into everyone's house and so
it's a it's a continuous your question
of translation I think is part of that I
thank our speaker